Roughly 66 million years ago,
our planet went through one of the most large scale extinction events in the
history of multicellular life forms.
Entire classes of species were wiped off the face of the earth.
Others changed beyond all recognition in order to adapt to the new conditions
and survive.
The reasons for this dramatic event are still not known for certain still.
There is no doubt that the creat Paleogene extinction made great changes to
what our planet looked like.
The majestic and horrifying dinosaurs were superseded by creatures,
not less impressive mammals.
The.
Three fourths of all living organisms on earth died out in the OUS.
Paleo gene extinction arm restore creatures heavier than 25 kilos ceased to be
including practically all non-Asian dinosaur.
This tragic event,
heralded the end of the Mesozoic and the beginning of the San Zoic.
The geologic era that is still not over it is divided into three periods
of various duration,
which are different both in terms of climate and diversity of the biosphere.
The first and longest is known as the pay Le gene.
It began around 66 million years ago and continued for 43 million
years in the first 10 million years of the paleo gene,
the Earth's biosphere was recovering from the hard blow dealt by the mass
extinction.
This geological EPAR is referred to as the paleo scene since great numbers
of dinosaurs and other species of the creats had perished.
There were lots of VA technological niches for the taking.
These were promptly filled by the new masters of our planet. Mammals.
The geography of the earth of that period was drastically different from what
we're used to seeing today, looking at ma up of that prehistoric earth,
we would already be able to make out the familiar continents,
but they were positioned slightly differently.
Thus north and south Americas were separated by tropical seas while the Indian
subcontinent was just starting to make for the Asian shores.
The prehistoric ocean known as the death is still lay between Africa and
Eurasia,
but was already largely giving way due to the movements of tectonic plates.
The climate of the epoch was warmer and more stable than today's.
Most of the planet was covered with dense and lush, tropical forests.
The overwhelming majority of the living creatures the day were quite small,
thanks to the abundance of vegetable food.
They propagated and spread across more and more new areas.
This is when the prehistoric ancestors of most of today's mammals thrived.
For example, the warm forests of the paleo gene were inhabited by my SIDS,
small and Def predators that looked like Martins.
It has believed that they were the progenitors of all.
Today's rich diversity of Mamal predators at around the same time,
their lived ACO seats,
the prehistoric ancestors of today's whale at the time. However,
they looked more like hippos. They hadn't gone to live in the sea yet.
It had made their first steps in that direction. Their limbs,
respiratory organs in the Inre had already started to adapt to prolonged stays
underwater.
The next steep a car planet went through was the year seen.
It began approximately 56 million years ago and continued for slightly over
2 million years,
the contours of the continents had already grown to be quite recognizable.
India had finally made it to the Southern shores of Asia.
And as a result of the collision of tectonic plates, giant rock folds formed.
That is how the Himalayas rose the largest mountain range in our planet
today, even though some species of that time already looked like some,
we might come across today, others were completely different.
An example of one of these is Andrew SARS.
One of the largest mammal predators that has ever lived on the earth.
It skull measured up to 84 centimeters,
which is roughly one and a half times more. Other than that,
of the brown bear and its bite is estimated to have been harder than that,
of any of today's land predators.
It has been inferred from the deep tooth sockets in Andrew SAS's skull,
where Manil muscles were attached to which leaves no doubts as to the bites
crushing force reconstruction of its skeleton shows that the animal could
measure four meters and length and weigh as much as a ton.
Still, interestingly,
it looks like this giant car fell into the class of primitive ungulates research
showed that Andrew Sark's closest relatives were the prehistoric soy forms,
hippos ans studies of a few unearthed fossils with scar and teeth show that
the animal must have been Omni NIS,
and even didn't mind eating cion unfortunately not many bones
and fossils of this fascinating creature have been found,
and scientists are still at TODs as to the structure of its organism habits and
relation to other mammal families.
The Orus scene was the last tea bark of the paleo gene. It is that it,
that it began around 33.9 million years ago and was over about
23 million years ago,
which makes it roughly 11 million years long.
This was a time of global cooling.
The warm tropical forests were gradually superseded by endless prairies covered
with grasslands.
This is when the end targeted glaciation began and an icy shield
transformed the green continent into the pole into a lifeless code.
Desert Australia continued to drift away from the other continents while Africa
on the contrary was making for the north to meet Europe after a collision of
tectonic plates, mountain ranges formed.
And that is how the Alps made their appearance on the map of the world around
26, 20 8 million years ago,
the super volcano lag Rita furiously erupted on the territory of today's
Colorado. In fact act,
it was one of the major volcanic emissions of the entire fan.
Zoic eon an area of over 30,000 square meters was buried
under a layer of hot as,
as much as a hundred meters thick all life within a huge radius round,
the volcano was destroyed completely.
Amazingly life is able to come to terms with any disasters.
The earth of the time was inhabited by fascinating creatures.
Some of which were not smaller than dinosaurs in size. For example,
Indra Ethereum, a prehistoric herb before related to rhinos.
Parisa Ethereum. The largest of these reached 4.8 meters in sheer length,
which is higher than a large African elephant.
Thanks to their remarkably long neck.
These giants were able to raise their head up to seven meters above the ground.
Today's rhino would be able to pass under its enormous progenitive belly while a
human would hardly reach up to touch its knee with our mass reaching 20 tons.
These giants were the largest land mammals of all times,
even Brotus sous the most massive of land dinosaurs weighed just around
15 tons. It still hasn't been established for certain what and Dr.
Ethereum looked like, unfortunately,
not one entire skeleton of these amazing animals has been excavated so far
only separate fragments from different animals of the species.
Most scientists agree that in spite of their relation to rhinos in Dr.
Ethereum didn't have a massive horn,
although it may well have had a small nose trunk like today's tapers the trunk,
would've allowed it to pick juicy leaves off treetops.
These giant herbivores must have lived in herds and were constantly on the move
around vast stretches of land roaming across their dominions in search of
food. Unfortunately, by the end of the scene,
Indra Ethereum had died out completely at around the same time.
The areas they used to inhabit were explored by prehistoric elephants,
alongside large predators, high inner dance and DHIS.
The latters are also known as bear dogs.
It is thought that the emergence of new large herbivores would've greatly upset
nature's balance. And in Ethereum,
would've been forced to fiercely compete for its food famine and the threat from
the nude dwellers of the ancient Prairie gradually to the herbivores giants
total extinction.
Apart from those mentioned,
there were some other large predators who were quite common on the earth and the
period from 37.2 to 28.4 million years ago,
and tele dance fossilized remains of these creatures have been found all over
Eurasia being even to donates and Teles resembled wild
boars.
Although in terms of evolution,
these creatures are closer to hippos orations measuring up to two meters
in length. They weighed over a ton.
A meter long head had huge jaws complete with all sorts of teeth,
sharp in sizes, long fangs and wide flat MOS.
It is likely that in intelligence were omnivores with a preference for
predation, not hampered by their impressive size and bolt.
They were able to develop remarkably high speeds. So chances of our Tron,
such a monster, quite thin, a wild boar,
the size of a large bull that prefers meat posed a serious threat to any
inhabitant of the earth of that time.
That is why it is hardly surprising that int successfully struggled for their
survival for such a considerable time.
The period in the history of our earth that came next was the near gene.
It approximately 23 million years ago,
and ended just 2,580,000 years ago.
This is when our planet started to look almost,
but not quite what it looks like today.
The continents shifted to their today's positions on the planet surface and the
looks of the most of the plants and animals of the day to be familiar Tori with
the Earth's climate gradually becoming colder and with droughts occurring more
often polar caps were gradually growing,
which culminated in a global glaciation at the end of the near gene, the planet,
meanwhile was crawling with all sorts of fascinating creatures.
The deep seed dwellers were terrorized by a giant shark,
measuring 15 meters in length and weighing up to 35 tons
on land.
Various gopher.
Ethereum could be seen creatures related to today's elephants.
Many of them were the proud owners of four solid tusks as for the animals size.
Some were larger than today's Frick elephant,
whereas others were quite modest in comparison around
2.5 million years ago, there started the Ry,
which is currently the last geologic period in the history of the earth.
It is remarkable for the emergence and evolution of homo sapians as was its
prehistoric ancestors.
For example,
the period from 1 million years ago to a hundred thousand years ago,
their lived jargon.
Tous one of the species of great humanlike apes known to science.
They measured three to four meters in height and weighed over 500
kilograms.
These creatures lived on the territory of Asia and were related to today's Arran
town.
It appears that gigantic EPIs would not be able to climb trees like other
humanlike apes on account of its mass.
However,
some of them are known to have dwelt in mountainous areas and made homes and
natural grottos caves and ravines,
even though their diet is believed to have consisted of mainly bamboo bones of
herbivorous animals with tooth marks were unearthed in their shelters,
judging by these fines.
It is safe to assume that these creatures didn't mind meat and where arm NIS at
the very least the gigantis skeleton is similar to that of a gorilla.
So they were likely to use all four limbs to move around.
Besides these human, like apes had a comparatively large brain,
which means that they could be relatively intelligent and were probably able to
even make primitive working tools. Unfortunately,
the population of these amazing giants sharply dropped when the prehistoric,
as of today's human emerged as spread across the planet by around one to
300,000 years ago, they had died out completely.
Sadly not many remains of gigantis have been found,
which greatly impedes studying them as they were spreading across the earth.
Primitive human tribes eliminated many other creatures.
One of their victims was mega EUM.
A giant grounds human tribes came to south America. The powerful,
but sluggish giant was helpless under a barrage of sharp Spears and arrows.
And very soon its population dropped to zero
other giants who supposedly became extinct because of humans were Diprotodon,
which inhabited Australia in the period from 1.6 million years ago to around
40,000 years ago,
these creatures were the largest known MAOS and they were related to wombats and
koalas.
Some of these amazing animals reached as much as three meters in length and two
meters in she height as for their mass, they weighed approximately three tons.
This makes Diprotodon quite as big as some hippos,
massive and Habis.
They dwelt on massive Woodland and coastal grass covered planes that bowed in
Australia before humans had made their appearance there chronologically
the extinction of the mass giants coincides with first human tribes arriving to
the continent.
Still some scientists maintained that the extinction was caused not by hunting,
but an anomaly of the Earth's magnetic field together with a local temperature
decrease the heightened radiation background,
coupled with cooling slowed down plant growth,
which led to Farine among the herbivores. Thus it appears at, by by and large,
the tragedy was inevitable and the humans simply brought it to a close faster.
The last tea bark of the Ry,
the Hollen Herald did a robust development of the human civilization when homo
sapians spread across the entire planet and dominated all the other inhabitants
of our earth.
The downside of this evolution is manifested in a number of industrial disasters
and irreversible changes in nature's balance. For example,
it is due to human activity that the greenhouse gases concentration in the
earths atmosphere is getting worse every year.
This may globally negatively affect all living things on our earth from
simplest bacteria to elaborate multicellular organisms.
Unfortunately,
the number of fascinating creatures living on our earth is going down every
year.
It is particularly Poyant to realize that the per because of human stupid or
on controlled hunting,
irresponsible land development and indifference to the environment have already
made scientists speak in you sixth great extinction event whose
consequences are potentially just as grave as those of the previous five will
mankind stop before it eliminate itself.
How long should it take our planet to recover from the consequences of the
technological progress and will nature produce radically new life
forms that would weather this crisis? Just like it happened before.
We can hardly realistically answer these questions,
Have a chat with your friends about this.
If you feel strongly about the issues raised here and give us a thumbs up.
If you enjoyed the video, as you know,
it takes us a lot of time and effort to make every video interesting and
informative. And your support means the world to us.
Let's keep in touch.
The, um,